cats might have nine lives but the film
adaptation of cats was basically dead on
arrival
perhaps it sounds overly dramatic to
declare Tom Hooper's cats a full-fledged
cinematic calamity but at this point the
facts are rather indisputable now after
a few weeks and theaters the film stands
to lose a whopping 100 million dollars
for universal that's even after its
unprecedented theatrical re-release
which found the filmmakers attempting to
fix the terrifying and ever off footing
CGI felines seems like they scrambled
and they rushed to re-edit the film
meanwhile the studio quietly yanked cats
from it's for your consideration page
effectively ending the film's Oscar
campaign before it had a chance to
really begin don't make us say it the
film is one serious catastrophe between
its abysmal box-office performance and
wildly low rotten tomato score it's
clear that audiences and critics really
didn't care for cats and just looking at
the trailers it's not too hard to see
why so what went wrong with this
Broadway sensation turned box office
stinker well in a recent reddit thread
several VFX technicians who allegedly
worked on the film reveal what went down
behind the scenes and the situation if
true sounds pretty dire apparently we
can place the blame squarely on
impossible deadlines unrealistic demands
and numerous poor decisions made by
Hooper we've used digital technology to
create the most perfect covering of fur
these are people but their cats and this
is kind of blowing my mind
as we mentioned Universal pulled a
stunning move shortly after the film hit
theaters announcing that cats had to be
re-released in order to address some
very obvious cgi blunders for one there
was the generally unsettling look of the
human faces haphazardly pasted onto
digital cat bodies not to mention a
major mock-up involving Dame Judi
Dench's cat character old Deuteronomy
that particular mistake was publicized
by varieties Jenelle Riley who wrote on
Twitter this isn't a joke Katz was
rushed into theaters before being
finished so
new version is being sent to theaters
with updated effects how do you know if
you have the old version look for Judi
Dench's human hand wedding ring and all
and also worth noting the production
schedule was reportedly so rushed Hooper
kept maniacally working on what was
meant to be the final cut of the film
right up to cats premiere on the red
carpet he told variety i finished it at
8 a.m. yesterday after 36 hours in a row
I just put the finishing touches on so
I'm very happy to be here with it fully
finished the premiere should be the
first time people get to see it and this
is genuinely a premiere meanwhile we got
this covered sums up the reddit thread
by noting that quote pour requests from
the studio and ridiculously short
deadlines made quality work near
impossible in fact someone claiming to
have worked on the film's visual effects
wrote blame the director and clients for
their lack of realistic requests
according to another supposed VFX
technician often cats were missing lairs
lights and Kryptos were unusable broken
but you couldn't ask for a rear ender
unless there was something egregious
like a whole cat missing the show was
one uphill battle for every artist and
supervisor involved with a client that
could only identify what they didn't
like and who wouldn't offer any clues as
to how to get what they did like we did
what we could another editor added the
timelines of these productions is the
thing that's frustrating this movie
still may have been a flock even if it
had been done well but the super short
schedule is what killed this movie well
as you can see for yourself the end
result looks incredibly bizarre perhaps
one of the biggest problems with cats is
that the movie feels rather Driftless
and purposeless adapted into a stage
play by Andrew Lloyd Webber from a book
of poetry by TS Eliot called
old possum's book of practical cats the
musical follows The Adventures of a
group of London Street cats each of them
yearns to ascend to the so called
Heaviside lair in order to be reborn at
the end of the day it turns out that a
bunch of singing cats fighting over who
gets to die isn't what box-office
bonanzas are made up audience members
who did
wind up watching the film likely left
the theater wondering what the hell
they've just seen we have the answer for
that one they've just seen one of the
biggest box-office bombs in recent
memory check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite and least
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one